I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everybody. Hi, guys. We wanted to wish you a really happy, happy Thanksgiving. Yes, happy Thanksgiving. We are on vacation. I'm probably eating chocolate pie, as I speak. Oh, yeah. There's a very, very, very good chance that while you're listening to this, I am eating bread and pie. But we wanted to share with you guys our season one,
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好。大家好。我们想祝大家感恩节快乐。是的，感恩节快乐。我们在休假。我说话时可能正在吃巧克力派。哦，是的。你听这个的时候，我有很大很大的几率正在吃面包和派。但我们想与大家分享我们的第一季，
second drink, revisited episode where we answer fan questions and we talk about all of those things we missed. Yeah. So you might have heard a portion of this when it originally aired as part of our candy bag episodes over on Stitcher Premium. But we are bringing it here for the holidays. We're basically covering everything from the pilot to hot girl. So like season one. All the stuff, all your questions. And there's some really good ones. We love it when you guys send these in. So hopefully, you know, while you're eating your leftovers, you can listen to us gab away. I re-listen to it. I love it. Even though I recorded it, I forgot stuff. What does that say about me? Maybe, maybe you need some ginkgo, right? You know what? Story for real,
第二杯特辑的重温剧集，我们在节目中回答粉丝的提问，并聊聊所有我们错漏的细节。是的。所以当这期节目作为我们在 Stitcher Premium 上的糖果袋剧集首次播出时，你可能已经听过一部分了。但为了假期，我们把它搬到了这里。我们基本上涵盖了从试播集到辣妹的所有内容。也就是第一季。所有的内容，你们的所有问题。而且里面有一些非常棒的问题。我们很喜欢你们发来这些。所以希望你们在吃剩菜的时候，能听我们闲聊。我自己又听了一遍。我太喜欢了。尽管是我录的，但我还是忘了里面的某些内容。这说明了我什么？也许，也许你需要吃点银杏，对吧？你知道吗？说真的，
lady. What? I got some ginkgo biloba to help my memory and I forgot to take it after. Come on. I'm not lying. I was like in college. Yeah. And I got the ginkgo biloba and I brought it home and my dad still gives me grief. By the way, I think it was a Thanksgiving break. I came home with my ginkgo biloba and my dad has never let me live it down. I love that it's become a classic go-to for your dad. That's like such a dad thing to do. Oh yeah. Really quick before we get into this, lady. What's your favorite Thanksgiving dish? I love good old-fashioned green bean casserole with the turkey fried onions on top. And by the way, I use canned green beans. I do not use fresh green beans. I do not use frozen fresh green beans, canned green beans in my turkey green bean casserole
女士。什么？我买了一些银杏叶提取物来帮助记忆，结果后来我忘了吃。拜托。我没撒谎。我当时好像在上大学。对。我买了银杏叶提取物，把它带回家，我爸爸到现在还拿这事取笑我。顺便说一句，我想那是感恩节假期。我带着我的银杏叶提取物回到家，我爸爸就一直没放过我。我喜欢这成了你爸爸拿来开玩笑的经典梗。这太像爸爸会做的事了。哦，是的。在我们在进入正题之前，女士。你最喜欢的感恩节菜肴是什么？我喜欢老式的青豆砂锅，上面铺着炸洋葱。顺便说一句，我用的是罐头青豆。我不用新鲜青豆。我不用冷冻新鲜青豆，我的火鸡青豆砂锅用的是罐头青豆
with a good can of mushroom soup. I look forward to it every year. I do love that. Oh, I love that. I love like my mom's gravy and I don't know how she does it. I mean, no store-bought gravy, no restaurant gravy will ever top this gravy. I think she takes like all the what's left in the pan, you know, and then she adds flour to it and whatever. I don't know what all she does to it, but I will drizzle that gravy on anything. It is so good. All right, Jenna, should we get into this? Yeah, let's do it. Now, I have a couple of questions. These are for you, Angela. I was looking in our mailbox and I've got a couple of questions for our background expert. Oh, Lord, that's you. So Haley said, at the end of the pilot episode, there is a cartoon drawing just behind Jim's
配上一罐好吃的蘑菇汤。我每年都盼着它。我真的很喜欢那个。哦，我太喜欢了。我喜欢我妈妈做的肉汁，我不知道她是怎么做到的。我是说，没有任何市售肉汁或餐馆肉汁能比得上这个肉汁。我想她是把锅里剩下的所有东西，你知道的，然后加入面粉之类的东西。我不知道她具体是怎么做的，但我会把肉汁淋在任何东西上。太好吃了。好了，珍娜，我们该进入正题了吗？好吧，我们开始吧。现在，我有几个问题。这些是给你的，安吉拉。我在我们的信箱里看到了一些针对我们的背景专家的提问。天哪，那指的就是你。海莉说，在试播集结束时，吉姆的
head on the shelves where they have office supplies and paper, etc. Does anyone know what this drawing is? Angela, can you help us out? Okay, Haley, I saw that too. These things drive me crazy as well. I want to know who would just cut up like cartoons and actually not do a very good job cutting. It looks like they rip them out and they tape them to the wall. This is like the second time I've noticed one of these. Well, this was in a time because when I worked in an office, if you saw something funny like a cartoon that you thought was funny, that's what you did with it. You didn't post it on your Instagram because you didn't have Instagram. You cut it out and you put it like, but you usually put it in the break room. I mean, this is just randomly taped to the
头后面、摆放办公用品和纸张等的架子上，有一幅卡通画。有人知道这幅画是什么吗？安吉拉，你能帮帮我们吗？好吧，海莉，我也看到了。这些东西也把我快逼疯了。我想知道谁会把卡通画剪下来，而且剪得其实并不好。看起来像是直接撕下来然后用胶带贴在墙上的。这好像是我第二次注意到这种东西。好吧，这是在一个特定的时代，因为当我在办公室工作时，如果你看到什么有趣的东西，比如你觉得好笑的卡通画，你就会这么做。你不会把它发到 Instagram 上，因为当时没有 Instagram。你会把它剪下来，然后贴在——但你通常会把它贴在茶水间里。我的意思是，这只是随随便便用胶带贴在
wall, but I took a photo of it from the TV and zoomed in. Do you see it, Jenna? Oh, yeah. It looks like it's been ripped out of a magazine. See how it's like. It looks very New Yorker to me. Yeah. It's like a New Yorker cartoon. And it looks like a woman in an office. There's a plant behind her. There's like a bar graph on the wall. And it looks like the man in front of her has something all over his back. Do you see that? Yeah. Or maybe an animal attached to his back. We don't know because it goes by so fast. I mean, I did a burst photo on that thing and that's the best I got. So Haley, I am sorry. I don't know what that comic means other than maybe one of our prop guys thought it was funny and he taped it to the wall. Well, I have a tidbit about something
墙上，但我用电视拍了张照片并放大了。你看到了吗，珍娜？哦，是的。看起来像是从杂志上撕下来的。你看它那个样子。我觉得它看起来非常像《纽约客》的风格。对。就像《纽约客》的漫画。看起来像是一个办公室里的女性。她后面有一株植物。墙上好像有一个条形图。而且她前面的那个男人的背上好像沾满了什么东西。你看到了吗？是的。或者也许是一只动物趴在他的背上。我们不知道，因为这个镜头一闪而过。我的意思是，我对那个画面拍了一组连拍照片，这就是我能得到的最好的效果了。所以海莉，我很抱歉。我不知道这幅漫画是什么意思，除非可能是我们的道具人员之一觉得好笑，然后把它用胶带贴在墙上了。好吧，我有一个关于背景墙上某个东西的趣闻，大家都会觉得很有趣。是什么？它在迈克尔的办公室里。在墙上。它装在框里吗？它装在框里。所以在迈克尔的墙上，有一份装裱好的证书，装裱的方式就像你装裱高中毕业证、大学毕业证那样。那是你非常引以为傲的东西。是的。迈克尔装裱了一份他的手表的证书。他买这块手表时，附带了一份证书。上面写着：真品证书。兹证明迈克尔·斯科特（他不得不自己把名字写上去）是精工（Seiko）优质时计的自豪拥有者。现在，精工（Seiko）是一款手表。问题是，精工的拼写是 S-E-Y-K-O，这意味着迈克尔为他的山寨
that's in the background on the wall that we can all enjoy. What is it? It is in Michael's office. It's on the wall. Is it in a frame? It's in a frame. So there is on Michael's wall a certificate that's framed in the way that you might frame your high school diploma, your college diploma. Something you're very proud of. Yes. Michael has framed a certificate from his watch. When he bought his watch, it came with a certificate. And it says Certificate of Authenticity. This certifies that Michael Scott, and he had to write in his own name, is the proud owner of a quality Seiko timepiece. Now, Seiko is a watch. The problem is Seiko is spelled S-E-Y-K-O, meaning Michael has framed a certificate of authenticity for his knockoff
精工手表装裱了一份真品证书。是的。是的。而且他还自豪地把它挂在办公室里。是的。他拥有一块手表的证书。一块假手表的。一块假手表的。我觉得迈克尔可能会买一个相框，里面夹着一张看起来很棒的家庭照片作为样板照片，然后就一直把它放在那儿。哦，我觉得这在某一集里出现过。我觉得有一集里，他就一直留着相框里自带的那张样板照片。好吧，我还有另一个问题要问你，安吉拉。好的。好的，这是泰勒问的。她说，很明显，文件柜垃圾桶的笑话在简那里行不通。你还记得那一幕吗，她说：“你收到我的传真了吗？”我说：“他把它扔进了一个充当垃圾桶的特殊文件柜里？”好吧，迈克尔掩饰说，引述：“这个笑话原本是我兄弟的。”
Seiko watch. Yes. Yes. And he's proudly displayed it in his office. Yes. His certificate of ownership of a watch. Of a fake watch. Of a fake watch. I feel like Michael might buy a picture frame that has a really nice looking family as a stock photo and just leave it up. Oh, I think that's in an episode. I think there's an episode where he keeps the stock photo of whatever came with his frame. All right. I have another one for you, Angela. Okay. All right. This is from Taylor. She says, clearly, the filing cabinet trash can joke doesn't go over well with Jan. Do you remember that scene where she's like, did you get my facts? And I say he threw it in a special filing cabinet that's a trash can? Well, Michael covers it up by saying, quote, the joke was originally my brothers.
泰勒说，迈克尔有个兄弟？我觉得关于他的家人，我们只听说过他的妈妈和继父杰夫，从没听说过有什么兄弟姐妹。安吉拉，你能告诉我们什么？你知道吗？这真是一个好问题，因为除了他们似乎不是很亲近、也没有真正陪伴在他身边之外，我们确实对迈克尔的家人知之甚少。在整整九季中，他经常谈到他对杰夫的鄙视。他的继父。他的继父，我觉得这非常搞笑。但他确实提到他有一个兄弟。他有一句台词说：“我爱我的大哥。”然后他还有这样一句台词：这个笑话是他兄弟的。所以他确实提到了一个兄弟。然后他在
Taylor says, Michael has a brother. I feel that in regards to his family, we only hear about his mom and stepfather Jeff, but never any siblings. Angela, what can you tell us? Well, you know what? That is such a good question because we really don't know a lot about Michael's family other than the fact that they don't really seem to be very close and they haven't really been there for him. He often talks about throughout the nine seasons, his disdain for Jeff. His stepfather. His stepfather, which I find very funny. But he does mention that he has a brother. He has a line where he says, I love my big brother. And then he also has this line that this joke was his brother. So he does reference a brother. And then he also references what appears to be his nephew in the
任人唯亲那一集里，还提到了一个貌似是他外甥的人。他提到了他的外甥，人们就在想，也许那是同母异父的姐妹生的，也许是他妈妈和杰夫生的。所以除了他可能经常一个人呆着之外，关于迈克尔家人的信息并不多，因为看起来他妈妈改嫁给了杰夫，也许他大哥不在身边。我认为迈克尔在成长过程中可能是一个有点悲伤的孩子。我认为当他的父母离婚时，无论他当时几岁，这对他打击真的很大。而杰夫也对他的影响很大。但编剧们并没有在这个上面深入探讨太多。不过我很高兴他确实有这样的背景故事。这就是为什么他会有动力把办公室当成他的家庭。这也是为什么他如此渴望一个家庭。这也是为什么你会原谅他在追求这一切时犯下的所有错误，以及为什么他会表现得如此强烈。我们为你提供了关于他的这种背景故事。这些小片段表明他在成长过程中并不快乐。这让他不再只是一个夸张的电视角色，而变成了一个真正的人。我认为我们的编剧在赋予所有角色这些能使他们成为血肉丰满的人的小背景故事方面做得非常棒。这也是为什么你最后会支持迈克尔去和霍莉过上生活。是的，因为他终于找到了属于他的人，并且他将拥有一个家庭。现在让我们继续盘点我们在“多元化日”中错漏的细节。梅根·G 等人说，嗨。在“多元化日”的播客中，珍娜提到她办公桌后面的那个巨大碎纸机从来没有
nepotism episode. He mentions his nephew and where people are thinking, maybe that's from a half sister, maybe from his mom and Jeff. So there's not a lot of like information about Michael's family other than the fact that he probably was alone a lot because it seems like his mom remarried Jeff and maybe his big brother was away. I think Michael was kind of maybe a sad kid growing up. I think when his parents got divorced, whatever age he was at, it really affected him. And Jeff really affected him. But the writers really don't go into it very much. But I love that he does have that backstory. And this is why he's motivated to make the office his family. It's why he longs for a family so deeply. And it's why you forgive him for all
使用过。但在“带女儿上班日”里，她不是和梅德里克斯的儿子一起碎了一些东西吗？是的，各位。我漏掉了这个。我真的很抱歉。是的。帕姆最终试图赢得某个小孩好感的方式，就是向梅德里克斯的儿子展示那个巨大的碎纸机。我要正式声明，我认为那是我们唯一一次使用那个大碎纸机。而且我觉得当我们最终使用它时，这是一个笑梗，因为那东西已经在那里放了那么久了。我敢肯定当我们打开它的时候，里面都长蜘蛛网了。就像是，我觉得它都不能用了。它一定得修理一下。还得想办法组装拼凑一下。好吧，另一个细节是会计部门后面的那扇门，在梅德里克斯的办公桌和会计部之间。我们从不
the mistakes he makes in wanting this and why he comes on so strongly. We give you this backstory about him. These little nuggets that he was not happy growing up. And takes him from just being a big over the top TV character to being a real human being. And I think our writers did a great job of giving all the characters those little backstories that made them fully fleshed out people. And it's also why you root for Michael in the end to go have a life with Holly. Yes, because he finally has his person and he's going to have a family. Now let's move on to what we missed from Diversity Day. Megan G, among others, said, hi. In the Diversity Day podcast, Jenna mentioned that the huge shredder behind her desk was never
使用它。我们从不从它里面进出。这是一个巨大的谜团。最终在第九季中，我们看到了这扇门后面是什么。但你知道门后面真正是什么吗？是洗手间。洗手间。还有视频村（监视器区）。是的，休息室。制片人可以在那里观看我们拍摄的内容，也是我们去洗手间的地方。最后，关于“多元化日”那一集，谢尔比写道，为什么吉姆的额头上没有多元化卡片？谢尔比，我不知道。但这是一个很棒的观察点。为什么吉姆的额头上没有多元化卡片？我把那一集从头到尾找了一遍，也没弄明白他是不是从来没有过。我隐约记得他好像自始至终都没有。
used. But didn't she shred some things with Meredith's son on Bring Your Daughter to Work Day? Yes, everyone. I missed this. And I'm so sorry. Yes. The way that Pam finally tries to get some kid to like her is that she shows Meredith's son the giant shredder. I will go on record saying I believe that is the only time we ever used the big shredder. And I think it was a joke when we finally used it that it's been sitting there for all this time. I'm sure when we turned it on, like cobwebs came out of it. It was like, I don't think it worked. I think it had to be repaired. It had to like rig it somehow. Well, something else is the door behind accounting between Meredith's desk and accounting. We never
等等。我给 BJ 发了短信。BJ 是怎么说的？他没有回我。我去了 Dunderpedia。对。好的。Dunderpedia 就像是专门针对《办公室》的维基百科。上面列出了每个人以及他们额头上的卡片。而吉姆没有。上面没有吉姆的记录。这是一个谜。而且它也将永远是个谜。在删减片段中，菲利斯贴的是“海地人”，德文贴的是“西尼罗河病毒”。是的。但吉姆额头上从来没有出现过贴纸。是因为约翰留了刘海吗？我觉得不是。看看他的头发，告诉我你怎么可能把便签卡贴在他的额头上。我不知道。我觉得吉姆不知怎么就是成功地躲过去了。他不就像那种能逃避这种事的人吗？不知怎么的。
use it. We never go in it. We never go out of it. And that was a big mystery. And finally, in season nine, we see what's behind the door. But you know what was really behind the door? Was the bathrooms? The bathrooms. And video village. Yeah, the green room. The green room where producers could watch what we were filming and where we went to the bathroom. And finally, from the Diversity Day episode, Shelby wrote, why didn't Jim have a diversity card on his forehead? Shelby, I don't know. But great thing to point out. Why didn't Jim have a diversity card on his forehead? I looked all through there, and I could not figure out if he never had one. I kind of remember him never having one.
就像他会很鬼祟一样，因为他很酷。显然。好了，各位。嗯，也许我们该休息一下。我喜欢。好的。让我们进入“医疗保健”那一集。海瑟写信说，在 4 分 50 秒时，有一个简短的讨论，说雷恩嘴里可能含着一根棒棒糖。她说那是一根牙签。安吉拉，你能证实一下吗？海瑟，情况是这样的：我现在配了远视眼镜。是新的。我现在看剧集时都戴着它们。海瑟，为了你，我专门重新观看了“医疗保健”这一段。我觉得你是对的。我觉得那是牙签，而不是棒棒糖。不戴眼镜时，看起来像棒棒糖。戴上眼镜后，我想，嗯，我敢打赌那是牙签。你看到了细节。布雷特在 5 分
Well, wait. I texted BJ. And what did BJ say? He didn't get back to me. I went over to Dunderpedia. Yeah. Okay. Dunderpedia is like the Wikipedia just for the office. And it lists every person and the card on their forehead. And Jim does not have one. There is no listing for Jim. This is a mystery. And it's just going to remain so. Phyllis has Haitian in a deleted scene and Devin has West Nile in a deleted scene. Yes. But Jim does not ever appear with a sticker on his forehead. Is it because John had bangs? I don't think so. Look at his hair and tell me how you'd put a note card on his forehead. I don't know. I think somehow Jim just managed to get out of it. Doesn't he seem like the kind of guy that would get out of something like that? Somehow.
5 秒时说，梅德里克斯身后的墙上有一张照片。那是鲍勃·巴克吗？是的，就是他。布雷特，是的，那就是鲍勃·巴克。好的。而且看起来像是从杂志上撕下来的。鲍勃穿着一件条纹衬衫。他坐在沙发上。我发誓这曾在杂志上出现过。它就在下方不远处。那里有一张用图钉钉在墙上的绿色斯克兰顿威尔克斯巴里墙壁地图索引册。就在它正下方，是坐在沙发上的鲍勃·巴克。我们觉得这是角色梅德里克斯贴在墙上的吗？她喜欢鲍勃·巴克吗？你知道吗？这很符合她的人设。他晒得很健康。他很有钱。是的。他可能知道拉斯维加斯最好的自助餐在哪里。好吧。这是梅德里克斯会喜欢的类型。下一个问题。这是约翰问你的，安吉拉。既然我们
Like he would just like sneaky because he's cool. Clearly. All right, guys. Well, maybe we should take a break. I like it. All right. Let's get into healthcare. Heather wrote in and said, there is a brief discussion about Rain maybe having a lollipop in his mouth at four minutes, 50 seconds. She says it's a toothpick. Angela, can you confirm? Heather, here's the deal. I have now gotten glasses for far away. They're new. I now wear them when I watch the episodes. And I rewatch this part of healthcare just for you, Heather. And I think you're right. I think it's a toothpick and not a lollipop. Without glasses, looked like lollipop. With glasses, I'm like, hmm, I bet it's a toothpick. You're seeing the detail. Brett at five minutes, five
知道凯文申请的是仓库的工作，但迈克尔却给了他会计部门的工作，这是否改变了你看待会计部门这三个角色之间互动的方式？安吉拉，我想说的是，你总是为凯文这个角色准备最惊人的背景故事。你愿意分享一下吗？大家听着，现在这个，我们总是取笑我的演员准备工作和我的帕姆文档，但安吉拉为凯文这个角色虚构了一个背景故事，她跟我分享过。以下是我关于凯文是如何得到这份工作的理论。我认为凯文的爸爸，老马龙先生，他以前可能是罗伯特·邓德和罗伯特·米夫林的球友兼朋友。他们是邓德·米夫林的联合创始人。这是一场任人唯亲。是的。我觉得马龙先生
seconds says there's a photo on the wall behind Meredith. Is that Bob Barker? Yes, it is. Brett, yes, it is Bob Barker. Okay. And it looks like it's torn out of a magazine. And Bob has like a stripe shirt. He's sitting on a sofa. I swear this was in a magazine. And it's just right below. There's a green Scranton Wilkes bar wall map index book that's been like thumb tacked. And right below it is Bob Barker sitting on a sofa. Is this something that Meredith, the character Meredith put on the wall, we think? Does she love Bob Barker? You know what? It fits. He's really tan. He's got a lot of money. Yes. He probably knows the best buffet in Vegas. All right. This is Meredith's kind of guy. Next question. This is for you, Angela, from John. Now that we
当时说：“你得雇我儿子。听着，我们知道他是个白痴。把他随便塞在哪个角落里。如果他惹出什么麻烦，我来买单。只要雇他，让他离家远点就行。”我觉得这也是为什么会有三个会计，因为你和奥斯卡有时不得不重做凯文的工作。一直都在重做。我有一句台词是这样的：当我们谈论被裁员时，我说，好吧，我觉得我知道哪个部门会被裁员。我的意思是，我们有，有一个部门三个人在做两个人的工作。这是我和奥斯卡之间的一段对话。我们当时在谈论凯文。结合你的背景故事，我觉得他爸爸来找他说“凯文，我要在这家纸业公司给你找份工作”，这一切完全说得通。你想到哪里工作？然后他说：“叉车。我想在仓库里搬东西。”我敢确定达里尔当时说：“不，不，不，不，任何迈克尔的手下都不行。”然后他就说：“把他弄到楼上去，让他离开我的仓库。”我们是自己编造出这个故事的。我们只是想让你们知道。这是我们自己的原创脑洞。约翰，这就是珍娜和安吉拉的同人小说。贾斯汀写信说，珍娜，你提到了你的“斯克兰顿之声”混音带。我在你的网站上找不到，想知道你会不会发布你的“斯克兰顿之声”播放列表。贾斯汀，是的。她会的，贾斯汀。我想让你知道她对此感到有点尴尬。但我告诉她，我说：“这正是它的迷人之处。”你必须把它放上去，我们这就这么做。现在已经在上面了。
know that Kevin applied for a job in the warehouse, but Michael gave him a job in accounting, does that change the way you look at the dynamic between the three characters in the accounting department? Angela, I want to say that you always had the most amazing backstory for the character of Kevin. Will you share it? This is guys, now this, we always make fun of my actor prep and my Pam document, but Angela has this backstory for the character of Kevin that she invented that she shared with me. Here's my theory for how Kevin got his job. I think Kevin's dad, Mr. Malone, senior, I think he was like golf buddies and friends with Robert Dunder and Robert Mifflin. They were the co-founders of Dunder Mifflin. It was a nepotism. Yeah. I think Mr. Malone
我只想说，那是一堆经典摇滚歌曲。我丈夫看到了这个列表，他说：“这根本说不通。这怎么能让你进入帕姆的角色？我不明白。”然后我向他解释，当我年轻的时候，我曾进行过漫长的公路旅行。作为珍娜，这就是我听的音乐。你听的是《Pour Some Sugar on Me》。我火热、黏腻、甜美，从头到脚。是的。经典摇滚在圣路易斯非常盛行。所以这把我带回了我作为珍娜的某个生活时期，当时我正在苦苦挣扎，当我开车去前台工作时，我不知道自己的人生在做什么。所以通过听那些音乐，它确实让我进入了一种心境。后来，当帕姆在第三季中对所有事情都非常沮丧时，当她对与吉姆的生活感到沮丧时，我
was like, you got to hire my kid. Look, we know he's an idiot. Put him somewhere in the corner. If he makes any problems, I'll pay it off. Just hire him, get him out of the house. I think this is also why there are three accountants because you and Oscar have to redo Kevin's work sometimes. All the time. And I have a line that's like, when we're talking about being downsized, I'm like, well, I think I know which department is going to be downsized. I mean, we have, there's one department that has three people doing the job of two. That's like a conversation Oscar and I have. We're talking about Kevin. With your backstory, I think it totally works that his dad came to him and said, Kevin, I'm going to get you a job at this paper company.
为帕姆创建了一个不同的播放列表。里面的歌曲都非常忧郁，有点像诺拉·琼斯和本·福尔斯的作品，我觉得这可能稍微更贴切一点。但答案是“斯克兰顿之声”。它现在已经上线 the officeladies.com 网站了。你可以找到它。而且我们也在考虑，如果你们反响很好的话，我们可能会制作一件“斯克兰顿之声”T恤。你们觉得怎么样？我觉得我们应该做。我丈夫说他会穿的。好的。现在我们要进入“联盟”那一集了。好的。这里有一份我们漏掉的所有细节的快速清单。显然，安吉拉，我们漏掉了很多。“愤怒女王”说，有那么一点失望，你没有提到在 9 分 49 秒时迈克尔文件柜上的便签，上面写着：“吹口哨和放屁”。
Where do you want to work? And he was like, forklift. I want to work with the things in the warehouse. And I'm sure that Daryl was like, no, no, no, no, any muscle Michael. And he was like, you put him up here, get him out of my warehouse. We have invented this. We just want to let you know. This is our own brainchild. John, this is Jenna and Angela fan fiction. Justin wrote in and said, Jenna, you mentioned your sounds of Scranton mix tape. I couldn't find it on your website and was wondering if you're going to post your sounds of Scranton playlist. Justin, yes. She is Justin. I want you to know she's embarrassed by it. But I told her, I was like, that's what's so charming about it. And you have to put it on and we're doing it. It's on there now.
让我告诉你一件事，“愤怒女王”。我也很难过我漏掉了那个。我回去重新看了“医疗保健”和“联盟”，我想让你们知道。实际上，你第一次看到“吹口哨和放屁”是在“医疗保健”那一集。咚，咚，咚，而不是“联盟”。哦，看“医疗保健”中 4 分 7 秒处，你就会看到了。好吧，你这么说很有趣，因为劳伦提到在“联盟”这一集的 4 分 7 秒处，你看到一个男人在帕姆的头后面走过时消失了。是的。我把那一幕倒带看了大概三遍，因为起初我以为那只是德文路过或者克里德路过，你知道的，因为他们会，我们的导演会让他们在背景里走动，这样当有人在会议室里对着镜头做独白时，办公室看起来仍然很忙碌、在正常运作。所以我又看了一遍，你是对的。就像是他们剪辑过一样，德文走到一半，然后他就直接消失了。哇。是的，好眼力，劳伦。扎内尔说，在 6 分 20 秒时，镜头切到坐在办公桌前的帕姆，她穿的是一件紫色条纹衬衫，而不是她在这一集其余部分穿的粉色衬衫。好吧，我其实想为你鼓掌，扎内尔。因为我回去重新看了这一幕，花了我好一会儿时间，因为那件紫色条纹衬衫——剪辑师之所以使用它并希望没人发现，大概是因为它露出的只有她的右肩膀。那是极其短暂的一瞬间，而你注意到了。所以，为你鼓掌。非常棒。那么现在我们有一些关于
I just want to say it is a bunch of classic rock songs. And my husband saw the list and he said, this makes no sense. How did this get you in the character of Pam? I don't understand. And I explained to him when I was younger and I went on long road trips. This is what I listen to as Jenna. You listen to pour some sugar on me. I'm hot, sticky sweet, from my head to my feet. Yeah. Classic rock was really big in St. Louis. And so it brought me back to a time in my life as Jenna when I was struggling, when I was driving to my receptionist job and I didn't know what I was doing with my life. And so by listening to that music, it did get me in a headspace. Later, when Pam is really upset about everything in season three, when she is upset about her life with Jim, I
这一集的问题。阿尔林说，你们谈到一个场景，凯利因为嫌梅德里克斯话太多而烦扰了她，因而被调到了附楼，但我完全不知道这是什么时候发生的。我想澄清这一点。好吧，这个场景从头到尾都没出现过。这是我们在片场编造的一个背景故事，用来解释为什么只有托比和凯利在办公室的另一个独立区域工作。这个笑话是，迈克尔让托比坐在后面是因为他无法忍受托比，而凯利被调到后面是因为她喋喋不休的唠叨让办公室里的其他人都觉得有点烦。是的，这只是一种在片场即兴编造的故事，我们用来开玩笑解释他们为什么被调走。是的。他们被调走的真正原因是他们是编剧，他们不能出现在
created a different playlist for Pam. And it was all very moody, kind of like Nora Jones and Ben Folds, which I think maybe feels a little more on the nose. But the answer is Sounds of Scranton. It's on theofficeladies.com website now. You can find it. And we are also considering if you guys respond well, we might make a Sounds of Scranton t-shirt. What do you think? I think we should. My husband said he would wear it. All right. Now we're going to move on to the Alliance episode. Okay. Here is a quick list of all the things we missed. Apparently, Angela, we missed a lot. Angry Queen said, a tad disappointed you didn't mention the sticky on Michael's file cabinet at nine minutes, 49 seconds, that says, Whistle and All Fart.
每一个场景里。他们必须待在编剧室里。是的，他们得能够随时隐身。但我们开玩笑说，我们觉得原因是因为迈克尔讨厌托比，而凯利太爱唠叨了。是的。伊兹写信说，当迈克尔谈论 80 年代派对时，镜头切到 4 分 19 秒的新闻剪报。这篇文章全都是胡言乱语。好吧，安吉拉，我做了一次“安吉拉式”的操作。我也这么做了。我把画面放大了。我把那一幕画面定格了。我戴上眼镜，把整篇都读了一遍。好吧，它一开始确实是一份真正的新闻简报。但接着第二段就是它开始的地方。是的。你有吗？我有。我有。上面写着：“正如任何人都可以轻易看出的那样，这份新闻简报实际上并没有太多要说的。它真的只是一种用来填补一些空白的道具，看起来像是一份新闻简报，但实际上并没有多少新闻简报的内容，只是通过输入很多单词，然后开始输入一些胡言乱语的词汇。”这太菲尔·谢伊了。这是道具部门在自娱自乐。是的。他们经常这么做。我们有很多来自该剧的道具，尤其是你，安吉拉，你保存了下来。是的。我们以前好像聊过这个。聊过吗？我不确定。我是说，我保存下来的最喜欢的东西之一是一个道具，那就是德怀特和安吉拉的婚礼节目单。你把它打开，里面有各种各样的东西。那是菲尔·谢伊在自娱自乐。我太喜欢了。帕姆的婚礼节目单里也有故意拼错的好笑单词。我们在那一集中从来没有提到过，但我想象着，就像婚礼上经常发生的那样。你拿到节目单，你会想：“哦，什么？他们把兄弟的名字拼错了？”而且那是故意的。他们会做这种事。梅丽莎·唐写信说，我希望你们能谈谈仓库那一幕里捕鼠器里的假死老鼠。实际上很多人都写信来问这个。大家对这只死老鼠有很高的兴趣。安吉拉，你能告诉我们什么？我能告诉你的是：在 13 分 17 秒时，有一只黑色的老鼠，它躺在那个推车旁边，你知道吗？
Let me tell you something, Angry Queen. I'm sad I missed that too. I went back and rewatched Healthcare and the Alliance, I want you to know. And actually, the first time you see Whistle and All Fart is in Healthcare. Bum, bum, bum, not the Alliance. Ooh, look at four minutes, seven seconds in Healthcare and you're going to see it. Well, it's funny you say that because Lauren mentions that at four minutes, seven seconds in the Alliance, you see a man vanish while walking behind Pam's head. Yeah. I rewound that like three times because at first I thought it was just like Devin doing a cross or Creed, you know, because they would, our directors would have them do background crosses so that the office looked like it was still busy and functioning while there were
吉姆正在用胶带封箱子，有一只黑色的老鼠侧躺着，把捕鼠器当成枕头，你甚至能看到它在动。这就是有人写信来说的内容。而且它明显是假的。我需要知道到底是怎么回事，难道有个道具师拿着一根线让它的头在动吗？我告诉你，我给菲尔·谢伊发了电子邮件，给菲尔·谢伊发了短信。我正试图弄清真相，我很抱歉，但我认为他在度假。他没有回我。要么就是菲尔·谢伊现在讨厌我了，但我尽量不把它放在心上。菲尔·谢伊可不是那种会故意不回你消息的人，珍娜。我觉得他在度假，而且他大概很需要这样一个假期。所以我们可能得重新探讨一下那只老鼠的问题，但这是我注意到的另一件事。这是一个连贯性错误，但我也禁不住想，是不是有人告诉他们把老鼠弄走。因为在 13 分 17 秒时，你看到了老鼠，但在 13 分 27 秒时，没有老鼠了，连捕鼠器也没有了。所以我有点怀疑他们是不是惹上麻烦了什么的。好吧，也许这是在第一条拍摄中拍的，
people in the conference room doing their talking heads. And so I rewatched it and you're right. It's like they edited and halfway across Devin is making a cross and then he just disappears. Wow. Yeah, good catch, Lauren. Zanelle says that at six minutes, 20 seconds, the show cuts to Pam at her desk and she is wearing a purple striped shirt instead of a pink shirt she was wearing in the rest of the episode. Okay, I actually want to applaud you, Zanelle. Because I went back and rewatched this and it took me a minute because that purple striped shirt and probably why the editors used it and hope no one would catch it is literally just her right shoulder. It is such a quick moment and you got it. So applause. Very good. So now we have some questions about
然后他们把它拿掉了，因为它看起来太假了。当然。但吉姆封箱子的第一条拍摄是最好的一条。所以他们用了那条，然后呢，你知道的，在后面的拍摄中就没有了，因为这种事情经常发生。是的，所以就变成了有老鼠、没老鼠。沃伦和豪尔赫写信说，在这一集中，我们得知乳制品会让梅德里克斯生病。然而在“荒岛求生”中，梅德里克斯说她真的很喜欢恶魔食品蛋糕。这是一个连贯性失误，还是她只是为了这个蛋糕愿意冒一切风险？我觉得梅德里克斯会为了她最喜欢的蛋糕冒一切风险。我的意思是，我觉得她会一时冲动冒所有风险，你知道的，尤其是那个加了牛奶的饮料，那个卡鲁阿咖啡甜酒的东西。卡鲁阿咖啡甜酒加奶油。她会觉得：“明天我再来承担后果。”是的。是的。
this episode. Arlind said, you talked about a scene where Kelly gets moved to the annex because she bugged Meredith from talking too much, but I have absolutely no idea when this was. I wanted to clear this up. Okay. This scene never occurs. This was a made up backstory that we came up with on the set as the reason why just Toby and Kelly work in this whole other section of the office. The joke was that Michael made Toby sit back there because he couldn't stand him and Kelly got moved back there because she was sort of annoying everybody else in the office with her chatty chat. Yeah, this was just a sort of onset sort of like made up story that we would joke about why they were moved away. Yeah. The reason they were moved away was because they were writers and they couldn't be
所以我不知道这是否是一个刻意的连贯性错误，但我觉得更有可能是一种刻意的选择。好的。这是玛丽提的最后一个问题。在这一集快结束时，当罗伊与吉姆对峙时，镜头摇向植物旁的德怀特，在梅德里克斯办公桌上方，墙上有一张照片。那是一张脚的照片吗？是的，玛丽。是的。这是一个惊人的发现。天哪，玛丽，为你鼓掌。在 20 分 57 秒时，你必须仔细看，因为那不仅是一张小照片。那是一张非常大的脚的照片。其中一只脚比另一只脚更显眼。脚趾甲涂了指甲油，而且你们看，并不是整只脚。它只是脚趾和脚背的一部分。真的很奇怪。我不知道这代表什么，
in every scene. They had to be in the writer's room. Yeah, they had to be able to disappear. But we joked that we thought it was because Michael hated Toby and Kelly was too chatty. Yes. Is wrote in and said, when Michael talks about the 80s party and they cut to the news clipping at four minutes, 19 seconds. The article is a bunch of gibberish. All right, Angela, I did an Angela. I did it too. I zoomed in on it. I froze that screen. I put on my glasses and I read the whole thing. Well, it starts out as a real newsletter. But then the second paragraph is where it starts. Yes. Do you have it? I do. I do. It says as anybody can easily tell this newsletter doesn't really have a lot to say. It's really just a prop to fill in some space and sort of look like a
但我觉得这太神奇了。我很想让我们采访一下我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格。是的。因为他们负责了许多这样的小细节，但我认为与他交谈会是一个非常有趣的人。我有很多问题想问他。我想知道所有的卡通画是怎么回事，还有那张从杂志上剪下来放在沙发上的鲍勃·巴克是真的吗？我百分之百确信。好吧，而且他们会轮流更换道具。我非常喜欢那种对细节的关注，每星期道具都会有所不同。女士，我们该休息一下吗？我觉得我们应该休息一下。我们回来了。所以我们从“性骚扰”开始。曼迪·拉奈。曼迪下划线拉奈。
newsletter without really being much of a newsletter at all by typing a lot of words and then it starts to type gibberish words. This is so Phil Shea. This is the props department amusing themselves. Yeah. Which they did often. We have a lot of props from the show, you especially, that you saved, Angela. Yes. Where we've talked about it before, I think. Have we? I don't know. I mean, one of the, my favorite things I saved was a prop and it is Dwighton Angela's wedding program. You open it up and it's got all of this stuff in there. That was Phil Shea having fun. I love it. Pam's wedding program as well has a bunch of funny misspelled words in it on purpose. We never address it in the episode, but I like to imagine as happens with
没准。她在谈到托比与德怀特对话后的独白时说，为什么自动售货机里的所有东西都是反着放的？哦，好眼力。好眼力，曼迪。嗯，你知道，可能我们没有获得展示那些商品的版权。而且有时你必须让公司同意在你的节目中亮相。是的，有时公司甚至会付钱让你在节目中亮相。但更重要的是，如果你确实看到了某个标志或类似的东西，它必须通过审核，因为也许他们不想与你扯上关系。是的，这有点像法律问题。所以自动售货机里有一些东西。也许我们当时想，哦，等等，所有人都能看见那些。把它转过去。
weddings. You get your program, you're like, oh, what? They misspelled the brother's name? And it was on purpose. They would do that stuff. Melissa Dawn wrote in and said, I hope you talk about the fake dead rat in the trap in that scene in the warehouse. A lot of people wrote in about this actually. A lot of interest in the dead rat. Angela, what can you tell us? Here's what I can tell you. At 13 minutes, 17 seconds, there is this black rat and it's laying by that cart, you know? Jim is taping up the box and there's this black rat laying on its side, like using the trap as a pillow and you even see it move. That's what someone wrote in and said. And it's clearly fake. I need to know what the heck was there a prop guy with a string that made its head
是的，这不是——但这多奇怪啊。但我觉得这是一个非常非常棒的眼力。这是一个很好的观察。好的，有一个问题来自，看起来像是雷蒙下划线 23 下划线 2016。在这一集中，他们说梅德里克斯有两个孩子，但随着剧集的推进，这减少到她只有一个儿子。是我记错了还是我疯了？我查了圣经。哦，我是说剧本圣经。我查了剧本圣经。这太疯狂了。这是一个极其疯狂的观察。好吧，在剧本圣经中，这两点都有列出。所以关于梅德里克斯的那一页，首先写着她离过两次婚，有两个孩子。德怀特在“昂迪奖”那一集里也说过这个事实。但接着在第二季第 11 集又有一个引用。剧本圣经上说她
move? I will tell you, I emailed Phil Shea, I texted Phil Shea. I'm trying to get to the bottom of this and I apologize, but I think he is on vacation. He has not gotten back to me. Either that or Phil Shea now hates me, but I'm trying not to take it personally. It's not like Phil Shea would ghost you, Jenna. I think he's on vacation and he probably much deserved vacation. So we might have to revisit that rat question, but here's the other thing I noticed. It's a continuity error, but I also have to wonder if someone told them to get rid of the rat. Because at 13 minutes, 17 seconds, you see the rat and then at 13 minutes, 27 seconds, there is no rat, there is no rat trap. So I kind of wonder if they got in trouble or something. Well, maybe it was in the first take
有一个孩子，没有丈夫。然后到了第五季第 18 集，剧本圣经中有一个引用说，她为了获得假期生了第二个孩子。听起来很像梅德里克斯会做的事。是的。太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。所以到底是怎样的？这是一个谜。我的意思是，梅德里克斯的一生都是个谜，真的。有点像。而且我想也许编剧有时只是为了笑话的效果而改变了设定。是的，没错。我觉得这有时确实会发生。有时一个笑话实在是太棒了。例如，帕姆的妈妈，我们是如何重新选角帕姆的妈妈的，因为他们有一个情节实在是太棒了。对。所以有时这是你无法掌控的。有时可能只是编剧的连贯性失误。也许他们只是没查阅剧本圣经，或者查了却不在乎，
and then they got rid of it because it looked too fake. Sure. But then that first take of Jim taping the box was the best one. So they used it and then, you know, it wasn't in later takes because stuff like that would happen. Yeah. So there's like rat, no rat. Warren and Jorge wrote in and said, in this episode, we learned that dairy makes Meredith sick. However, in Survivorman, Meredith said she really prefers devil's food cake. Was this a continuity miss or was she just willing to risk it all for this cake? I think Meredith would risk it all for her favorite cake. I mean, I think she would risk it all on a whim, you know, like especially what's that drink that with the milk, the Kahlua thing. Kahlua and cream. She would be like, I'll pay for it tomorrow. Yes. Yes.
因为他们太喜欢那个笑话了。各种原因都有可能。但没错，“好眼力”把我引向了剧本圣经，我不得不去查个究竟。我想我们在“性骚扰”这一集里没漏掉太多东西，安吉拉。我查看了所有的电子邮件和所有的评论。我不会把那种事说出去的。哦，好吧，这就是那两个。这就是那两个地方。好的，好的，好的。好的，这里有一个来自帕蒂·舒夫纳 76 的有趣事实。我太喜欢这个了。她写信来说，SAS 鞋是在德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥制造的。SAS 代表圣安东尼奥鞋匠。而且你可以去参观他们的工厂。天哪，我们应该去。你会喜欢那样的。我们应该去，安吉拉。天哪。我那安息的祖母，愿上帝保佑她的灵魂，一定在某个地方说：“去 SAS 工厂吧。”
So I don't know if it was an intentional continuity error or not, but I feel like more likely it was a choice. Yeah. All right. Here's our last question from Mary. Near the end of the episode, when Roy confronts Jim, it pans over to Dwight next to the plant and above Meredith's desk is a photo on the wall. Is that a picture of feet? Yes, Mary. It is. And that was an amazing catch. Oh my gosh, Mary, applause. At 20 minutes, 57 seconds, you have to look because it's not just a small picture. It's a really big picture of a pair of feet. One foot is a little bit more featured than the other foot. The toenails are painted and it's not the whole foot, you guys. It's just like the toes and like the top of the foot. It's really odd. I don't know what it means,
她太喜欢她的 SAS 鞋了。我会很想去的。我去过佛罗里达州基韦斯特的那家鞋厂。什么？对。什么？那里有一些皮革凉鞋，只在佛罗里达州基韦斯特制造。当我还是个十几岁的小姑娘时，我和妈妈进行了一次家庭度假，我买了一双这种凉鞋。它们只要 8 美元。我太喜欢它们了，后来他们开了一家网店。但你唯一能买到它们的方式，就是给他们寄一张银行认证支票。但价格大概是 15 美元。凉鞋本身 8 美元，再加上运费。我买了好几年。连续好几年，我都要走进银行开一张认证支票，然后把它寄给这家基韦斯特制鞋作坊，因为它们是最舒服的。是那种像你的海军蓝鞋子吗？对，
but I thought that was amazing. I'd like us to interview Michael Gallenberg, our set designer. Yes. Because they were responsible for a lot of these little choices, but I think he would be a very interesting person to speak with. I have so many questions for him. I want to know like all the cartoons and like, is that Bob Barker on a couch from a magazine? I'm positive. Well, and they would rotate things. I love that attention to detail that things would be different each week. Lady, should we take a break? I think we should. And we're back. So we'll start with sexual harassment. Mandy Lanay. Mandy underscore Lanay.
蓝色的那种。是的。是的。珍娜，我对你夏天每天都穿那双鞋有着如此深刻的记忆。是的。每天都穿。安吉拉，我现在还在穿它们。你现在可以直接网购了，不需要认证支票。我很失望。我想不起来它们叫什么名字了。抱歉，各位。这不是它们的广告。不，不。这只是，我真的很喜欢这双凉鞋。我确信如果你在谷歌上搜索像“基韦斯特佛罗里达凉鞋”这样的关键词，就能找到它们。听着，事情就是这样。我外祖母一辈子都穿 SAS 鞋。你找到一双喜欢的鞋，就会一直穿下去。没错。我愿意跟你一起去参观这个工厂。那一定很有趣。好的。斯蒂芬·托马斯写信说，在比赛期间有一个连贯性错误。一个镜头显示菲利斯和帕姆、安吉拉一起坐在长椅上，
That's right. Said in the talking head that Toby has after his conversation with Dwight, why is everything turned around backward in the vending machine? Oh, good catch. Good catch, Mandy. Well, you know, probably we didn't have the licensing to feature those items. And you have to sometimes have companies agree to be featured on your show. Yeah, sometimes companies will even pay you to be featured on a show. But more than that, if you do see a logo or something, it has to be cleared because maybe they don't want to be associated with you. Yeah, it's kind of a legal issue. So there were things in that vending machine. And maybe we're like, oh, wait, you can see all of that. Let's turn it around.
当镜头切换到比赛时，菲利斯在上场比赛。然后她又回到了长椅上。其实我也注意到了这一点。我注意到好几次她先是坐在我们旁边，然后镜头一切她就不见了。所以，斯蒂芬，好眼力。确实发生过这种情况。我觉得我们拍得有点不按顺序，那是一个连贯性错误。所以好眼力。我记得菲利斯有时和我们坐在长椅上，有时在场上比赛。而凯特总是和我们坐在长椅上，但她有点坐在桌子上。记得吗？对。对。这是我们的最后一个发现。汤姆下划线 AV8R。我猜他是汤姆下划线飞行员（aviator）。嗯，AV8R。那是缩写。看起来是这样。好的。而且我想说他不是
Yeah, isn't that but what an odd thing. But I thought that was a really, really good catch. That's a good catch. All right, we have a question from, it looks like Ramon underscored 23 underscore 2016. In the episode, they say Meredith has two kids, but as the seasons go on, it drops down to her just having one son. Am I right or am I crazy? I checked the Bible. Oh, the show. I checked the show Bible. And this is crazy. This is a crazy, crazy observation. Okay, in the show Bible, it lists both of these things. So on the Meredith page, first it says she is divorced twice and has two kids. And Dwight says this fact in the Dundies as well. But then it has another reference from season two, episode 11. The Bible says she
对啊，是不是？但这多奇怪啊。不过我觉得这个发现真的太棒了。真是个好发现。好了，我们来看一个观众的提问，看起来是Ramon下划线23下划线2016发来的。在这一集中，他们说梅雷迪思有两个孩子，但随着剧集的发展，变成了她只有一个儿子。是我记错了还是我疯了？我查了剧本圣经。哦，是这部剧。我查了剧本圣经。这太疯狂了。这是一个非常非常疯狂的观察。好吧，在剧本圣经里，这两点都列出来了。在梅雷迪思那一页上，首先说她结过两次婚，有两个孩子。德怀特在《邓迪奖》里也说过这个事实。但后来在第二季第11集又有了一个引用。剧本圣经说她
has one kid and no husband. Then in season five, episode 18, there is a reference in the show Bible that says she had her second kid for the vacation time. That sounds like Meredith. Yes. That is crazy. That is crazy. So what is it? It's a mystery. I mean, Meredith's whole life is a mystery, truly. A little bit. And I think maybe the writers sometimes just for the purpose of a joke might have changed things. Yeah, that's right. I think that did happen sometimes. Sometimes a joke was just too good. For example, with Pam's mom, how we recast Pam's mom because they had a storyline that was just too good. Right. So sometimes it's out of your hands. Sometimes it might just be like a writer continuity error. Maybe they just didn't check the Bible or they did and didn't care
有一个孩子，没有丈夫。然后在第五季第18集，剧本圣经里有个引用说她生第二个孩子是为了假期。这听起来很像梅雷迪思。没错。太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。那到底是怎样？这是一个谜。我是说，梅雷迪思的一生都是个谜，真的。有点像。而且我觉得有时候编剧们可能只是为了开个玩笑而改变了一些设定。对，没错。我觉得有时候确实会发生这种情况。有时候一个笑话实在太棒了。比如潘的妈妈，我们为什么要重新选角扮演潘的妈妈，因为他们有一个太棒的剧情线了。没错。所以有时候这是不受你控制的。有时候可能只是编剧的连续性错误。也许他们根本没查剧本圣经，或者查了却不在乎
because they loved the joke too much. It could be any of those things. But yes, Good Catch sent me down to the show Bible I had to find out. I guess we didn't miss very much in sexual harassment, Angela. I went through all the emails and all the comments. I would not put that out there. Oh, well, these were the two. These were the two things. Okay, okay, okay. All right. Here is a fun fact from Patty Schufner, 76. I loved this. She wrote in to say, SAS shoes are made in San Antonio, Texas. SAS stands for San Antonio Shoemakers. And you can go visit the factory. Boy, we should. You would love that. We should go, Ang. Oh my gosh. My grandmother, God rest her soul, is somewhere being like, go to the SAS factory.
因为他们太喜欢那个笑话了。各种可能都有。但不管怎样，这个精彩的发现让我去翻了剧本圣经，我必须查明真相。我猜我们在性骚扰那一集里没漏掉太多内容，安吉拉。我把所有的邮件和评论都看了一遍。我是不会把那些放出去的。哦，好吧，这就是那两个。这就是那两个事情。好吧，好吧，好吧。好了，这里有一个来自帕蒂·舒夫纳76的有趣事实。我很喜欢这个。她写信说，SAS鞋是在德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥制造的。SAS代表圣安东尼奥制鞋商。你可以去参观工厂。天哪，我们应该去。你会喜欢的。我们应该去，安吉。哦天哪。我外祖母，愿她安息，一定在哪个地方说：去参观SAS工厂吧。
She loved her SAS shoes. I would love it. I went to that shoe factory in Key West, Florida. What? Yeah. What? There are these, there are these leather sandals that are only made in Key West, Florida. And I went on a family vacation when I was a teenager with my mom and I got a pair of these sandals. They're like $8. And I loved them so much and they eventually opened an online store. But the only way you could get them is if you sent them like a certified check from the bank. But it was like for $15. It was like $8 for the sandals and then shipping. And I did it for years. For years, I would go into a bank and I would get a certified check and I would send it off to this Key West foot because they were the most comfortable. Were they the ones like your Navy ones? Yes,
她太爱她的SAS鞋了。我会很愿意去的。我去过佛罗里达州基韦斯特的那家鞋厂。什么？对。什么？那里有这些皮革凉鞋，只在佛罗里达州基韦斯特制造。我还是个青少年的时候，和妈妈一起去那儿进行了一次家庭旅行，我买了一双这种凉鞋。只要大约8美元，我太喜欢它们了，后来他们开通了在线商店。但你唯一的购买方式是寄给他们一张银行认证支票。不过只要15美元左右。凉鞋本身8美元，再加上运费。我买了好几年。连续好几年，我去银行开一张认证支票，然后寄给基韦斯特的这家鞋业公司，因为它们的鞋最舒服。是不是那种像你海军蓝颜色的鞋？是的，
the blue ones. Yes. Yes. Jenna, I have such a strong memory of you wearing those shoes every day in the summer. Yes. Every day. Angela, I still wear them. You can order them now without a certified check. I'm disappointed. I can't remember the name of them. I'm sorry, everyone. This is not an ad for them. No, no. This is just, I really love these sandals. I'm sure you could find them if you Google like Key West Florida sandals. Listen, that's what happens. My grandmother wore sashes her whole life. You find a shoe you love, you stick with it. That's right. I would go to this factory tour with you. That would be fun. All right. Steph Thomas writes in and says, there was a continuity error during the game. One shot showed Phyllis sitting on the bench
蓝色的那种。是的。是的。珍娜，我对你夏天每天都穿那双鞋有着极其深刻的记忆。是的。每天都穿。安吉拉，我现在还在穿它们。你现在可以直接订购了，不需要认证支票。我有点失望。我想不起它们的牌子了。对不起大家，这不是它们的广告。不，不。这只是，我真的很喜欢这些凉鞋。我确信如果你谷歌搜索一下基韦斯特佛罗里达凉鞋就能找到。听着，事情就是这样。我外祖母一辈子都穿SAS鞋。你找到一双喜欢的鞋，就会一直穿下去。没错。我愿意跟你一起去参观这个工厂。那一定很有趣。好了，斯蒂夫·托马斯写信说，比赛期间有一个连续性错误。一个镜头显示菲利斯坐在长椅上
with Pam and Angela. And when the camera switched to the game, Phyllis was playing. Then she was back on the bench. I caught this too, actually. I caught a few times where she was like sitting next to us and then it would cut back and she wasn't there. So Steph, great catch. That did happen. I think we shot a little bit out of order and that was a continuity error. So great catch. I remember Phyllis was sometimes on the bench with us and sometimes playing. And Kate was always on the bench with us, but she was kind of sitting up on the table. Remember? Yeah. Yeah. This is our last catch. Tom underscore AV8R. I guess he's Tom underscore aviator. Well, AV8R. That's the abbreviation. It would seem. Okay. And I do want to say he was not the
和潘、安吉拉坐在一起。当镜头切回比赛时，菲利斯在上场打球。然后她又回到了长椅上。我也注意到了这一点，事实上。我注意到好几次她先是坐在我们旁边，然后镜头一切换她就不见了。所以斯蒂夫，观察得真仔细。确实发生过这种情况。我想我们拍摄时有点顺序颠倒，所以这是一个连续性错误。所以观察得真好。我记得菲利斯有时候和我们坐在长椅上，有时候在场上打球。凯特总是和我们坐在长椅上，但她有点坐在桌子上。记得吗？对。对。这是我们的最后一个发现。汤姆下划线AV8R。我猜他是Tom_aviator。嗯，AV8R。这就是缩写。看来是这样。好吧。我确实想说他不是
only person to point this out. But he says at 22 minutes, 25 seconds of our podcast, you said Michael's book is called How I Manage. And it is actually called Somehow I Manage by Michael G. Scott, over one million sold, more than the Bible, not surprised. Guys, yes, I apologize. Much better title, Somehow I Manage. I think Greg and Steve should get together and write Somehow I Manage. Wait, as Michael Scott? As Michael Scott, I think Greg and Steve could get together and they could write this business management textbook. I think it would be amazing. That would be hilarious. That would sell like hot cakes. Yes. Can we start an online campaign to make this happen? I now no longer care if we have
只有一个人指出了这一点。但他说，在我们的播客播出到22分钟25秒时，你说迈克尔的书叫《我如何管理》。而它实际上叫迈克尔·G·斯科特的《我偏要管理》，畅销一百多万册，比《圣经》还多，一点也不奇怪。伙计们，是的，我道歉。更好的书名，叫《我偏要管理》。我觉得格雷格和史蒂夫应该聚在一起写一本《我偏要管理》。等等，以迈克尔·斯科特的身份？以迈克尔·斯科特的身份，我觉得格雷格和史蒂夫可以聚在一起，他们可以写这本商业管理教科书。我觉得这会太棒了。那太搞笑了。那会像热蛋糕一样卖脱销。是的。我们能发起一个在线活动来让这成为现实吗？我现在根本不在乎我们是否有
an office reunion. I just want the book Somehow I Manage. Oh my gosh. This is my new pursuit. We're going to get a phone call from Greg and he's going to be like, guys, people are telling me that like you want me to write a book. What is this about? I know, I know. Moving on to Hot Girl, we got a fan question. Well, Hal wrote in and he says, I noticed that Pam Stanley and Amy Adams all made appearances on that 70s show. I'm curious what, if any, are the connections there? Angela, I looked this up because I was shocked by this. Here's what I found out. Leslie David Baker, who plays Stanley, myself and Amy Adams have all had guest appearances on that 70s show in different years and different seasons,
办公室重聚。我只想要《我偏要管理》这本书。哦天哪。这是我的新追求。我们要接到格雷格的电话，他会说，伙计们，人们告诉我你们想让我写本书。这到底是怎么回事？我知道，我知道。转到“辣妹”话题，我们有一个粉丝提问。嗯，哈尔写信说，我注意到帕姆、斯坦利和艾米·亚当斯都客串过《那红极一时的七十年代秀》。我很好奇，那里有什么联系吗？如果有的话是什么？安吉拉，我查了这个，因为我对此感到震惊。以下是我发现的：扮演斯坦利的莱斯利·大卫·贝克、我自己和艾米·亚当斯都在不同的年份、不同的季节客串过《那红极一时的七十年代秀》，
even with different casting directors. I could not find a common link, except that that 70s show was on for whatever, nine seasons. It was a very popular show. It'd be like saying, oh my gosh, these three actors were all on friends. Yeah. You know, it was on for a long time and they had a lot of guest stars. And I think that we were just those working actors just pounding the pavement, looking for work. And we all ended up on that 70s show. You know, Rainn Wilson and I both had recurring roles on Six Feet Under. Oh, I didn't know that. I knew Rainn's, but I didn't know you. Well, Rainn's was very famous. He had a very long running recurring role on that show. I did two episodes of that show and that was a dream come true. Some of those guest spots,
甚至连选角导演都不同。我找不到任何共同的联系，除了《那红极一时的七十年代秀》播出了，不管怎样，九季。这是一部非常受欢迎的节目。这就好比说，哦天哪，这三个演员都演过《老友记》。是的。你知道，它播了很长时间，他们有很多客串明星。我觉得我们只是那些拼命拍戏、寻找工作的职业演员。我们最后都上了《那红极一时的七十年代秀》。你知道，雷恩·威尔逊和我都曾在《六尺之下》中扮演常驻角色。哦，我不知道那个。我知道雷恩的，但我不知道你。嗯，雷恩的非常有名。他在那部剧里扮演了一个很长时间的常驻角色。我拍了那部剧的两集，那是梦想成真。有些客串机会，
you know, where you get to suddenly, you're just this unknown struggling actor and all of a sudden you're on a set with a bunch of famous people on a hit show. And you're like, God, I hope I don't screw this up. I was the murderer on Monk. Oh, Tony Shalub was amazing. And I'm such a fan. And Alfred Molina was in the episode and I killed somebody. Oh my gosh, Angela. I once did a guest spot on a show where my character had a die. It was a medical drama. And my character got such a high fever that my brain melted and it was a result of doing drugs. I was playing a teenager. And my mom said it was the only performance of mine that has ever deeply disturbed her. She did not enjoy watching my heart flatline. Oh, no, no, no. No. Very upsetting. I wouldn't want to watch
你知道的，你突然发现自己只是一个默默无闻、苦苦挣扎的演员，突然间你就在一部热门剧集里和一群名人一起在片场。你会想，天哪，希望我没有搞砸。我是《神探阿蒙》里的凶手。哦，托尼·夏鲁赫太棒了。我是他的超级粉丝。阿尔弗雷德·莫利纳也参演了那一集，我杀了一个人。哦天哪，安吉拉。我曾经在一部剧里客串过一个角色，我的角色得死了。那是一部医疗剧。我的角色发烧得那么厉害，以至于我的大脑都融化了，那是吸毒导致的。我当时演一个青少年。我妈妈说，那是我唯一一个让她深感不安的表演。她一点也不喜欢看我的心电图变成一条直线。哦，不，不，不。不。非常令人沮丧。我也不想看
that either. No, no. Yeah. Okay. So that's it guys. I'm sorry. I wish that I had a better answer, but good observation. Very good observation. So William Warden 6547 wrote in Amy Adams might be my very distant cousin if she's also related to John Quincy Adams. William Warden, I have some good news for you. What? According to the internet, Amy is the 13th cousin eight times removed from our sixth president, John Adams, and signer of the Declaration of Independence. Does Amy know that? I don't know. Amy knows. Amy, I hope you know this. This is kind of amazing. Yes. You are a very distant cousin eight times removed from one of our founding fathers, as is William Warden 6547. All right. So those were some general hot girl comments, but let's get into the nitty gritty
那个。不，不。是的。好了，就是这样，伙计们。我很抱歉。我希望我能给出更好的答案，但观察得很仔细。观察非常仔细。所以威廉·沃登6547写道，如果艾米·亚当斯也和约翰·昆西·亚当斯有亲戚关系的话，她可能是我的远亲。威廉·沃登，我有个好消息告诉你。什么？根据互联网的说法，艾米是我们第六任总统约翰·亚当斯（《独立宣言》签署人）的八代表亲。艾米知道吗？我不知道。艾米知道。艾米，我希望你知道这一点。这真是太棒了。是的。你是我们国父之一的八代远亲，威廉·沃登6547也是。好吧。所以这些是一些关于“辣妹”的普遍评论，但让我们深入探讨
of the episode. Here is something a lot of fans had questions about the espresso machine. Angela. Well, let me just tell you, I did a deep dive on this. Here we go. Coffee machine correction. A lot of fans said it was an espresso machine. Correction from Kelly McNeil. You ladies said you weren't sure what happened to the coffee maker at the end of hot girl. Doesn't it make a reappearance in the episode where Michael renovates the Michael Scott paper company into cafe disco? Well, let me tell you. Angela. Here I go. I went way into the internet last night, guys. And here's the thing. In hot girl at 11 minutes 41 seconds, Michael says it is a Starbucks digital barista and it cost a thousand dollars. And you know what? I looked it up and it looks kind of boxy. Look, Jenna.
这集的细节。这里有很多粉丝对浓缩咖啡机有疑问。安吉拉。好吧，让我告诉你，我对这个进行了深入研究。我们开始吧。咖啡机纠正。很多粉丝说这是一台浓缩咖啡机。凯利·麦克尼尔的纠正。你们这些女士说你们不确定“辣妹”结尾处的咖啡机怎么了。它难道没有在迈克尔把迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司翻新成迪斯科咖啡馆的那集里再次出现吗？好吧，让我告诉你。安吉拉。我来了。我昨晚深入研究了互联网，伙计们。事情是这样的。在《辣妹》11分41秒时，迈克尔说这是一台星巴克数码咖啡师，价值一千美元。你知道吗？我查了一下，它看起来有点方。看，詹娜。
Oh, yeah. Right? Now in cafe disco, this is not the same machine. Oh, cafe disco. It's actually circular looking and it is called a Expressione Cafe Nova Centro. Oh, it's $400. Is it also from Starbucks? No, you can get this. It looks like on Amazon or Costco. Oh, I see. Oh, yeah. Completely different machine guys. Completely different. One looks like a boxy square. The other is like round with levers. Yeah. It has a sort of cylinder ask. Yes. I don't even want to tell you guys how long it took me to find this information out. I actually found the cafe disco express so cafe nova centro on Reddit. Reddit is an interesting place. Oh my God. So anyway, Sam is shaking his head. Yeah. Don't go to Reddit. Mom, don't go to Reddit. Well, I was looking for
哦，是的。对吧？现在在迪斯科咖啡馆，这不是同一台机器。哦，迪斯科咖啡馆。它实际上看起来是圆形的，叫做Expressione Cafe Nova Centro。哦，它只要400美元。它也是星巴克的吗？不，你可以买到这个。看起来在亚马逊或好市得都能买到。哦，我明白了。哦，是的。完全不同的机器，伙计们。完全不同。一个看起来像方盒子。另一个是圆的，带有杠杆。是的。它有点像圆柱体。是的。我甚至不想告诉你们我花了多长时间才找到这些信息。我实际上是在红迪网上找到的迪斯科咖啡馆浓缩咖啡机Cafe Nova Centro。红迪网是个有趣的地方。哦天哪。不管怎样，山姆在摇头。是的。别去红迪网。妈妈，别去红迪网。嗯，我在找
a coffee maker. Dang it. But here's the thing. It is not the same coffee maker. Well, I believe Phil Shea when he said we had to return it. It definitely isn't the exact same one because he returned it back to Starbucks to get his money back. And the one that I guess the one that we used it, the one that's in cafe disco, why did I read the reviews? But it's, um, it's much cheaper. Oh, I see. It doesn't always deliver. Well, that makes sense because Michael Scott Paper Company did not have as much money as Tundermilk. They would not spend $1,000. They would not. Yeah. All right. So more about the coffee maker. A lot of people would like us to answer the question who won the coffee maker. Remember, I bring up that we don't know. Well, Julia Sniffin found out something
一台咖啡机。该死。但事情是这样的。它不是同一台咖啡机。好吧，我相信菲尔·谢伊的话，他说我们得把它退回去。它绝对不是完全相同的那个，因为他把它退回星巴克去拿回退款了。我猜我们用的那个，迪斯科咖啡馆里的那个，我为什么要看评论？但它，嗯，便宜得多。哦，我明白了。它并不总是管用。好吧，这说得通，因为迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的钱没有邓德米福夫多。他们不会花1000美元。他们不会的。是的。好的，关于咖啡机的更多信息。很多人希望我们回答谁赢了咖啡机这个问题。还记得吗，我提起过我们不知道。嗯，朱莉娅·斯尼芬发现了非常
very interesting. Julia what? She said at 16 minutes 43 seconds Dwight is asking Katie on a date. And when she says no, he moves and you can see the leaderboard for the incentive prize. It says DM calendar blitz. Jim is in first place with $3,500 and Dwight is in second with $3,000. She says, I like to think that Pam wrote this. So I guess at that point, Jim is the leader. So technically Jim would have won the coffee maker. Right. But Michael was a little sour though about Katie going home with Jim. So that might not have worked out for Jim. Yeah. I like to think that at the end of the episode, Michael is just sipping coffee like he kept it. Why do I feel like he kept it? I feel like he kept it at his condo. I do too. That's what I think. Well, Tyler Wears
有趣的事情。朱莉娅发现了什么？她说在16分43秒时，德怀特正在约凯蒂出去。当她拒绝时，他走开了，你可以看到激励奖的排行榜。上面写着DM日历闪电战。吉姆以3500美元位居第一，德怀特以3000美元位居第二。她说，我愿意认为是帕姆写的这个。所以我想在那时，吉姆是领头羊。所以严格来说，吉姆本该赢得咖啡机。对吧。但对于凯蒂和吉姆一起回家，迈克尔心里有点酸溜溜的。所以这可能对吉姆没用。是的。我愿意认为在这集的最后，迈克尔正啜饮着咖啡，就像他把咖啡机留下来了一样。为什么我觉得他留下了它？我觉得他把它留在他的公寓里了。我也这么觉得。我也是这么想的。好吧，泰勒·威尔斯
also says, I was rewatching Hot Girl after listening to the last recap and I noticed the name Andy written on the conference room sales board at 14 minutes 36 seconds. Is this a complete coincidence or was this, you know, pointing at Andy Bernard, the character of Andy Bernard already in the plans. This must be a coincidence. It's a coincidence. There's no way they knew that early on that any of those extra characters were going to be storylines. There's no way. But I feel like this is what we talked about before, Angela, about these accidents that sort of stay in the ether of the office magic. Hey, you know, I will go down like a deep, deep dive on how I think there's a group mind in comedy and it's my improv background and that when people are all in this group mind,
也说，听了上一个回顾后，我又重看了一遍《辣妹》，我注意到在14分36秒时，会议室的销售白板上写着安迪的名字。这纯属巧合，还是说，你知道的，这已经在暗示安迪·伯纳德这个角色，安迪·伯纳德已经在计划中了？这一定是个巧合。这是个巧合。他们不可能那么早就知道任何这些额外的角色会成为故事情节。不可能。但我觉得这正是我们之前讨论过的，安吉拉，关于这些偶然留在办公室魔法以太中的意外。嘿，你知道，我会深入研究我为什么认为喜剧中存在一种集体意识，这是我的即兴表演背景，当人们都在这种集体意识中时，
these wonderful accidents that aren't accidents has happened, you know? Yes. Okay, sorry, I geeked out for a second, guys. I love it. Laura Sloss wrote, I loved the Hot Girl episode of the podcast. Thank you. She loved hearing about my poker tournament in Scotland. She lives in a town outside of Enboro and was wondering, do I remember the pub that I won the poker tournament in? Yes, I do. Yes, I do. It is called the Wally Dug and it is at 32 North Umberland Street. Laura said she's going to go by and see if my name is still on the leaderboard. Will you let me know? Oh, that would be great. If it is, you have to take a picture. Yes, please do. That is so cool. I feel like as soon as I walked out, they just erased it and they were like,
这些不是意外的美妙意外就发生了，你知道吗？是的。好吧，抱歉，我刚才有点狂热了，伙计们。我喜欢。劳拉·斯洛斯写道，我非常喜欢播客的《辣妹》那一集。谢谢。她喜欢听我在苏格兰的扑克锦标赛。她住在恩布罗郊外的一个小镇上，想知道，我还记得我赢得扑克锦标赛的那家酒吧吗？是的，我记得。是的，我记得。它叫沃利达格，位于诺森伯兰街32号。劳拉说她要去看看我的名字是否还在排行榜上。你能告诉我吗？哦，那太棒了。如果在的话，你得拍张照片。是的，请务必拍。那太酷了。我觉得我刚走出去，他们就把名字擦掉了，然后他们会说，
was it like dang American? Was it a dry erase board? It was. Oh, it is gone. Who are we getting? That's gone. I'm trying to remember what year that was. It was before my son was born. I think it was like 2009 or 2010. So we're going on a good nine or 10 years ago. Here's a question from Mali Brofsky and Shelby Garrick. They both asked, Jenna, when you sing at the end of the Hot Girl podcast, did you choose On the Wings of Love? Because that's what you sang at the funeral for the bird in grief counseling. It is. Really? Yes. I chose it and I wondered if anyone would notice. You planned it a little secret. Yeah. Well, when you said sing something, and we didn't plan that I was going to sing in that podcast, but when you said, why don't you sing something?
那像个美国人吗？那是块干擦白板吗？是的。哦，它不见了。我们迎来了谁？那个不见了。我在努力回想那是哪一年。那是我儿子出生之前。我想大概是2009年或2010年。所以那已经是差不多九十年前的事了。这里有一个来自马拉莉·布罗夫斯基和谢尔比·加里克的提问。他们都问，詹娜，当你在《辣妹》播客结束时唱歌时，你选择《爱之翼》是因为你在《悲伤辅导》里为小鸟举行葬礼时唱的就是这个吗？是的。真的吗？是的。我选了它，我想知道是否会有人注意到。你策划它作为一个小秘密。是的。嗯，当你叫我唱首歌时，我们并没有计划我要在那期播客里唱歌，但当你问，你为什么不唱首歌呢？
I was like, the first thing that popped into my head was a song that Pam sang. So finally, guys, I can't tell you how overwhelmingly positive the response was to our interview with Phil Shea, our props master. We got so many emails, so many comments about that, and we wanted to give you a little more. Yes. Phil actually was able to talk to us for a little bit longer than was in the actual episode, and he's just a wealth of information about the show. He answered more questions about the basketball episode and also the healthcare episode. So we're going to play that for you now. In the basketball episode, people had two big questions. One of the questions was the face mask that Rainne wears on his face. I remember that that was Greg's idea, and it was scripted,
我想，我脑子里第一个蹦出来的就是帕姆唱过的一首歌。所以最后，伙计们，我无法形容大家对我们采访道具师菲尔·谢伊的反应是多么的压倒性积极。我们收到了那么多的电子邮件，那么多的相关评论，我们想给你们带来更多。是的。菲尔实际上能够和我们聊的时间比实际播出的那一集要长一点，他简直就是关于这部剧的信息宝库。他又回答了关于篮球那一集以及医疗保健那一集的问题。所以我们现在要为你们播放那段录音。在篮球那一集里，人们有两个大问题。其中一个问题是雷恩脸上戴的面具。我记得那是格雷格的主意，剧本里写了，
but we never refer to it. Do you remember that? Is that something you had to find? Is that a prop or is that a wardrobe? It was a prop because it was basically something that would have been in Rainne's personal effects. He bought that sporting a sore head, an ophthalmologist's bill of form or a facial surgeon bill of form. So I guess Greg was in enamored with Alan Iverson, who wore one of those back in 2005. So I found a couple online, and we bought all three on and whichever one fit Rainne's the most face, the most appropriately, according to Greg's vision. That's the one we used. Crazy. Inspired by Alan Iverson. Yeah. Or somebody in the NBA who had broken their nose and came back in the game with that clear plexi face mask, and it was really
但我们从未提及它。你还记得吗？那是你需要去找的东西吗？那是道具还是服装？那是道具，因为它基本上是雷恩私人物品里会有的东西。他带着一副酸痛的脑袋买的，有一张眼科医生的账单表格或面部外科医生的账单表格。所以我猜格雷格迷恋上了艾伦·艾弗森，他在2005年戴过那种面具。所以我在线上找了几个，我们把三个都买下来了，根据格雷格的设想，哪一个最适合雷恩的脸，最贴合。我们就用了那个。太疯狂了。灵感来自艾伦·艾弗森。是的。或者是NBA里某个鼻子骨折、戴着透明有机玻璃面具回到比赛中的人，这在当时真的
the rage back then. So it was very, very topical and very current and relevant so that we kind of mimicked it that they had Rainne. That was pretty funny. Yeah. It was just one of the millions of gold nuggets that Greg always drops into the scripts that made it just a little scooch funnier and a little more mysterious. A little bit of layers there. Yeah. Great layers. Yeah. So I'm glad the fans inquired about all those little nuggets that Greg added to the show. Another thing people wanted to know about in that episode is the cold pack that burst open. Did you have to test cold packs? Like how did you make sure that this cold pack would burst open in the confetti-like way that Greg wanted? Yeah. We shook a bunch of them and tried to do it
非常风靡。所以它非常非常符合时事，非常当红且相关，所以我们模仿了这个，让他们给雷恩戴上。这挺搞笑的。是的。这只是格雷格总是塞进剧本里的数百万个点睛之笔之一，让它变得稍微滑稽了一点，也稍微神秘了一点。里面有一点层次感。是的。很棒的层次感。是的，所以我很高兴粉丝们询问了格雷格为该剧添加的所有这些小细节。人们想知道那一集的另一件事是那个爆裂开来的冰袋。你得测试冰袋吗？比如你是如何确保这个冰袋会按照格雷格想要的五彩纸屑般的方式爆裂开来的？是的。我们摇晃了一堆，试图让它
realistically and it never happened. And then we would score them. We would just take these little knives and kind of score them, which is basically weakening the fibers of the bag and then applied the same amount of pressure. And then we let Rainne practice with three or four so he could get an idea of how hard he needed to squeeze to want to break the bag. So that was just old school special effects or low tech, we call it really low tech. We got different bags. Poked a hole in them. The material. Well, not poking a hole, but more just like scraping, weakening. Yeah, weakening exactly. So Phil, a lot of people wanted to know more about the ice cream cake in the healthcare episode. Specifically, how many ice cream cakes did you have to buy?
表现得逼真，但这从未发生过。然后我们会给它们划痕。我们只是拿着这些小刀在上面划痕，这基本上是削弱了袋子的纤维，然后施加相同大小的压力。然后我们让雷恩用三四个进行练习，这样他就能了解他需要捏多大劲才能把袋子弄破。所以这只是老派特效，或者说低科技，我们称之为真正的低科技。我们拿了不同的袋子。在上面戳了个洞。材料。嗯，不是戳洞，更像是刮擦、削弱。是的，完全是削弱。所以，菲尔，很多人想了解更多关于医疗保健那一集里的冰淇淋蛋糕。具体来说，你必须买多少个冰淇淋蛋糕？
I think we did 30 and that was from the Baskin Robbins store on Victory Boulevard in Burbank and they delivered them in a refrigerated truck. Oh my God. Did we eat them all or did you have any leftover? We might have had four or five left over and I think we gave them a craft service. Oh man. I'm sure. Who ate them at craft service? Not the cast. I can tell you that much. We were all about to vomit. I gave it to craft service and I was just glad to be rid of them all. So the other ones didn't know who eats them or what you do with them, but they're not my responsibility. I know. I mean, they're perfectly fine cakes. They turned on us after eating them for hours and hours. You guys were troopers. Well guys, we hope you enjoyed this second drink
我想我们做了30个，是从伯班克胜利大道的巴斯金罗宾斯店买的，他们用冷藏卡车把它们送来的。哦天哪。我们把它们都吃完了吗？还是有剩的？我们可能剩了四五个，我想我们把它们送给后勤餐饮服务了。哦天哪。我敢肯定。谁在后勤餐饮服务那儿吃了？不是演员。我可以明确告诉你这一点。我们都快吐了。我把它送给了后勤餐饮服务，我很高兴终于摆脱了它们。所以其他人不知道是谁吃了它们或者你是怎么处理它们的，但它们不是我的责任。我知道。我的意思是，它们是完全没问题的蛋糕。但在连续吃了几小时后，它们开始让我们反胃了。你们真是一群硬汉。好吧，伙计们，希望你们喜欢第一季的第二杯饮料
of season one. Yes, and thank you so much for sending in your questions and your comments. And I want to say one thing, and we get a lot of people asking us, what is the best way to submit a question? Oh, well, I know that you have a certain way that you say it really helps. So let them hear it. Okay. My favorite because I like organization is when people submit questions through OfficeLadies.com because on our website, we have these little folders for each episode and you just click on the folder and then when it's time for us to prep that episode, I can go to that folder of questions. And they're all right there. They're all right there. Yeah. We also have, by the way, a general Q&A folder if your question doesn't fit into a specific episode.
。是的，非常感谢你们发来问题和评论。我想说一件事，很多人问我们，提交问题的最佳方式是什么？哦，嗯，我知道你有一种特定的表达方式，你说那真的很有帮助。所以让他们听听吧。好的。我最喜欢的方式，因为我喜欢井井有条，就是当人们通过OfficeLadies.com提交问题时，因为在我们的网站上，我们为每一集都有这些小文件夹，你只要点击文件夹，然后当轮到我们为那一集做准备时，我就可以去那个问题文件夹。它们都在那里。它们都在那里。是的。顺便说一句，如果你的问题不适合某个特定的剧集，我们还有一个通用的问答文件夹。
And but Lady, you get a lot of questions and comments from OfficeLadies pod or Instagram. Yes, I will go through Instagram comments. Jenna goes through folders. So there are multiple ways you can find us. And our associate producer Ainsley grabs things from our email, which is officeladiesatearwolf.com. So there's lots of ways. But we also get another question a lot, Lady, which is how far in advance do you need to send a question? Pretty far. Like four weeks. Yeah. We're about four weeks ahead on our podcast. So hopefully that helps so you can get your question answered. We also check those folders and comments after an episode has aired for these revisited. Yes, that's actually one of my favorite things is to see your comments. And like when
但是女士，你从OfficeLadies的播客或Instagram上收到了很多问题和评论。是的，我会浏览Instagram的评论。詹娜则浏览文件夹。所以你可以通过多种方式找到我们。我们的副制片人艾恩斯利从我们的电子邮件中抓取内容，邮箱是officeladiesatearwolf.com。所以有很多方法。但女士，我们经常被问到的另一个问题是，你需要提前多久发送问题？挺早的。大约四周前。是的。我们的播客大约提前四周。所以希望这能有所帮助，这样你的问题就能得到解答。在某一集播出后，我们也会查看那些文件夹和评论，用于“重温”环节。是的，实际上我最喜欢的事情之一就是看到你们的评论。就像当
Jenna got the synopsis of look who's talking wrong, the comments on OfficeLadies pod were making me laugh so hard. I like snort laughed. Did you love that, Ann? You loved it when I got it wrong. Well, no, just because we thought that was so funny. Guys, she snort laughed. I did. I loved it. I did. It's her favorite thing. Hey, hey, settle down because every week, I say some very simple phrase wrong. I guess true. It's like the latest one, by the way, is your mashup of Betty Crocker and Susie Homemaker. That was a private mashup. I left, I left Jenna a voicemail and I was just saying how I'm not great in the kitchen, you know, and I was talking to my husband and I was like, look, I'm not Betty Homemaker.
詹娜把《看谁在说话》的剧情简介弄错时，OfficeLadies播客上的评论让我笑得前仰后合。我笑出了猪叫声。你喜欢那个吗，安？当我弄错的时候，你很喜欢。噢，不，只是因为我们觉得那太搞笑了。伙计们，她笑出猪叫声了。我确实笑了。我太喜欢了。我确实笑了。这是她最喜欢的事。嘿，嘿，冷静点，因为每个星期，我都会把一些非常简单的短语说错。我想这是真的。顺便说一句，最近的一个是，你把贝蒂·克罗克和居家好男人苏茜揉捏到一起了。那是一个私人的混搭。我留下了，我给詹娜留了一条语音留言，我只是在说我不擅长厨房，你知道的，我在跟我丈夫说话，我说，看，我不是居家好女人贝蒂。
Yeah, she's not Betty Homemaker, everybody. Who is it? It's Susie Homemaker. Is it Betty? Either Susie Homemaker or Betty Crocker. Okay. Susie Homemaker kind of cleans the house and organizes it. I think she's sort of overall Homemaker and Betty Crocker is more kitchen-based, but I actually think you're getting it right, Angela. You are not a Betty Homemaker. Okay. Well, listen, neither one of those things are things you're super interested in. My skill sets are this. If you want someone to organize your pantry, if you have like all of your sort of wrapping paper and it's all in a bin all messed up with your ribbon, I'm going to go through, I will fold every piece of tissue paper. You will Marie Kondo that. But guys, I can't like
是的，她不是居家好女人贝蒂，各位。那是谁？是居家好女人苏茜。是贝蒂吗？要么是居家好女人苏茜，要么是贝蒂·克罗克。好吧。居家好女人苏茜有点像打扫屋子并整理它。我觉得她总体上算是个居家好女人，而贝蒂·克罗克更偏向于厨房，但我其实觉得你没说错，安吉拉。你可不是居家好女人贝蒂。好吧，听着，这两件事都不是你超级感兴趣的事。我的技能是这样的。如果你想让人整理你的食品室，如果你把所有的包装纸都放在一个箱子里，跟你的丝带弄得一团糟，我会去检查，我会把每一张薄页纸都叠好。你会像近藤麻理惠那样做。但伙计们，我不能
make a casserole out of just like extra stuff in the fridge. You're not going to want to eat that. I don't have that in me. I hear you. You're not a Betty Homemaker. I'm not a Betty Homemaker. All right, you guys, well, happy holidays. We hope you're having a safe and good one. And we just want to say we love you. Yeah, we love you. And we'll be back next week, breaking down an episode as usual. Bye. Bye. That's my turkey. I liked it. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
只用冰箱里的剩菜做一锅砂锅菜。你可不想吃那个。我可没这本事。我明白。你不是居家好女人贝蒂。我不是居家好女人贝蒂。好吧，伙计们，祝大家节日快乐。希望你们过得平安愉快。我们只想说我们爱你。是的，我们爱你。我们下周会回来，像往常一样解析一集。再见。再见。那是我的火鸡。我挺喜欢的。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由欧文、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的声音工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
For ad free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用一个月的StitcherPremium，请使用优惠码Office。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。